so today is day 3 of filming final wash
it's gonna be half the exo go to catch a
plane at some point today I'm going to
be doing an interview with Dom who's
ahead mammals here and from everything
I've heard is quite a character
I'm also gonna be doing favorites fear
also just bits and bobs of a footage
that you can cut into other videos and
more so because I'm seriously thinking
this far ahead I'm also going to be
filming some stuff for my project for
awesome video this year so doing here
it's the camera hopefully but I'm going
to try and do my some not busy and so
really not embarrassing we'll see how
that goes
there's our occupy okie from yesterday
you me are very lovely
at the moment there's at Arang and a
baby
making their way this way and I am so
desperate for has come a shock because
at the moment all of the stuff that just
at the camera has looked very much like
mostly orangutangs home habitat in that
it doesn't have orangutan
I feel like somebody meant for that to
happen
I don't think that could have got more
perfect okay so we just finished the
last lot of filming Dom whoo
really live fire under my house actually
and the best bottle work he really
really made me start thinking like these
issues very seriously and quite quiet
guy really passionate about this work he
could tell them this meant the world to
him
you
what people forget is that we are
a little ball floating in a very dark
hostile scary place space you know and
we're all if you like Earthlings on this
little planet to me those animals have
every right to exist on this planet
and to wash you know to just see them
disappear the absolute tragedy of it be
it's probably one of the worst things
that could ever do you know - just snub
out a form of life a species that's
evolved over hundreds of thousands of
years just because of our short termism
so it it's its right to exist as
paramount you know we should cherish
these things as the ultimate treasures
of the planet apart from that if we look
at this some planet that we live on this
wall floating around it's got this
fantastic regulating system that
regulates the climate the water the air
all these things that we take for
granted but the nuts and the bolts of
the system are the species within it the
pide tamarind for example the black line
tender fish they're all part of the
machine that keeps us on this habitable
planet so if we start chucking away the
nuts and bolts I almost don't disappear
in ultimately you know from a selfish
point of view that's going to have a
impact on us
yeah that's kind of a massive impact on
us so from a
altruistic point of view about that and
the beauty and the wonder of the planet
yes these animals have to survive but
also from a selfish point of view we
have to have these animals and these
species on the planet we are
intrinsically linked our futures are
intrinsically linked and we've got to
grow up and just recognize that fact
this we're just fooling ourselves and
robbing future generations of humans who
live on this planet if we don't stop and
think now I've now got to do my best to
make the best damn project for awesome
video possible because they need the
funds here they really do if there is
win project for awesome if they're to
get $100,000 or whatever watch the share
is going to be this year
it would really make a huge huge
difference in I owe it to them by the
best video I can really do at the moment
though that's it that that's the end of
this Jersey adventure I am going to be
getting on a bus distant Helia and then
another bus to the airport
so I guess I should sign off really I
don't want to go yet I really enjoy
myself I have well of course I am really
really really tired I mean I don't feel
ever had this but I guess it's because
I'm doing it by myself like I'm shooting
everything myself I'm trying to think
was on the fly doing all of that for
three days straight
he's absolutely exhausting so I am gonna
sleep very well tonight
but thank you for joining me on this
journey it's been nice to have somebody
I say somebody a canon g7x to take
around with me and the videos that I'm
really making featuring the interviews
and sort of talking about the big issues
here they're gonna come out a few weeks
so make sure you stay tuned for that and
I'm gonna be updated make sure you just
as opposed to the channel and all that
YouTube recently actually one last thing
I need to say thank you so much to Ric
for helping me coordinate this here
we've been such a willing interviewee I
wouldn't be not to do this without you
and yeah you've been really really
fantastic as is everybody here dad
launching so lovely so if you end up
watching this thank you everybody like
really really thank you you're so great
and if I can I hope I can do your works
injustice and gates and get you some
donations that I know so thank you very
much for hosting me and being so really
fantastic